[Musique]
par un certain Henri amer les
apiculteurs à l'époque avaient des
tendances à vouloir étouffer les
abeilles pour faire les récoltes mais ça
c'était un peu catastrophique parce que
les abeilles disparaissaient la plupart
mourraient et Henri Hamel au moment où
il a créé ce rucher pour pouvoir
justement enseigner nouveau nouvelle
manière de faire de la culture disait
c'est aussi bête d'étouffer les abeilles
que de vouloir couper un arbre pour
récupérer les fruits donc ça a été une
révolution
qui a été faite ici et ailleurs dans le
monde pour faire en sorte de faire des
apiculture responsables écologiques
faire en sorte que les abeilles soient
préservés et que on puisse récolter tous
les ans mais en leur laissant des
quantités suffisantes pour passer
l'hiver et en faisant attention à ce
qu'on fait cet esprit il a perduré et
donc c'est ici ce qu'on fait c'est un
peu dans la même dynamique le but c'est
de former des gens à une apiculture
responsable où on leur apprend les
techniques et on leur apprend à surtout
à préserver les abeilles ce capital
extraordinaire dans un jardin magnifique
avec de quoi polliniser très largement
les 23 ruches qu'il y a là